John McClane of Houston Chronicle how
are you John Rich I'm doing great how
are you I am doing fine how much should
we read into Deshawn Watson's
performance last night he looked really
good for Ritchie playing his first game
he was threw the ball away didn't force
it into coverage he didn't have a
turnover the overthrown some receivers
but it's not surprising to people that
have been watching in an offseason
program and the first two weeks of
pre-season up training camp
well tom savage was no slouch himself
nine of 1169 passing yards handicap what
what uh what's going on there with the
quarterback situation in Houston
averages the starter he was nine of 11
69 yards ninety-two Reagan got off to a
bad start
fans potential was awful they went to
know little groaned Matt he took him
straight down the field for touchdown
with the bench watch we came in lots of
fans wrench came up of Clemson people
are excited to think that he's an
exciting player but he is strictly the
backup he's thinking every second change
snap savages thinking every first thing
step so this is uh there's no there
there pretty much right now there's no
there there when it comes to Shawn
Watson saw the first game unless town
sandwich gets hurt in art in each of his
first three seasons so odds are it's
going to happen at some point I mean and
of all people to give Tom Savage the
seal of approval thumbs up and for the
starting position it is a Clemson Tiger
of the first variety and DeAndre Hopkins
as well well what what do we read into
all of that John well Hopkins and doors
turn back into many campy endorsed in
the first week training camp and then an
asthma guy came in last night in I mean
last week everybody acted like it was a
big deal but that's no surprise to
anybody there
Tom Savage is real big on making sure he
spends a lot of time with his receivers
off the field and even even Shawn Watson
talked about out there best friends
family hanging out away from football
Kevin is real big on that retching
that's part of being a leader
system inside out the players respecting
because he paid his dues so I'm with
John McLean year of Houston Chronicle I
know you're saying there's no there
there and I know you're saying that that
Watson's the backup and you know uh you
know better than anybody
all that said he's a first-round pick we
know Bill O'Brien has a lack of patience
on occasion he'll sometimes say
someone's my starter and then half time
makes a decision to go somewhere else
why shouldn't we think that would happen
again here John because thought Tom
Savage look real good after they changed
the strategy and team is coming off
winning records rarely start rookie
quarterbacks had started to see them
Russell Wilson took over losing team so
did dak Prescott so did Marcus Mariota
and Jameis Winston and Savage has paid
his dues no system he can handle Bill
O'Brien unlike Brock Osweiler evil
things starter when they begin the
season against Jacksonville lessee would
it just think it up in the next two
preseason games and Watson was great but
savages started for now and remember you
just pointed it out Bill O'Brien fits
the starter in Egypt's first free season
so the odds are central in order and get
benched so what is the major question
mark then involving the Houston Texans
going into the season best you can tell
John quarterback they got Tom Sanders
has never started
touchdown fast he's hasn't thrown an
interception he started two games he's
won in one he's endangered a lot and so
it's all about the quarterbacks rich
they got what they need to be to win the
division for the fifth time in seven
years three years in a row I don't think
they're suitable in there because you're
an AFC but you got a chance to at least
go farther in the playoffs it make it
finally finally get some production is
of consistency quarterback a few more
minutes here with John McClain in
Houston Chronicle I've got Brian Cushing
on the show tomorrow how is he JJ Watt
Jadeveon Clowney all those who were bang
last year how they looking JJ Watt
played the first series when healthy
doesn't play lol Bryan said every
player's out he's going to play in this
game block Blake one series the
fractions twice gets day off everything
they're doing is designed to have
another percent for the Jacksonville
game clown tees and really good shape
they listing it outside linebacker he's
like that a lot last night but people
still considering more of a defensive
end pushing very underrated last year
run stopping in in coverage pro Football
Focus poured out he's want to top inside
linebackers and phone and he's told us
in the hotel you rich the older it gets
the more exciting gets to play well you
are as you know not short on opinions
our poll question today is who wins the
AFC South I voted for the Tennessee
Titans I feel like they are ready to
roll they could take a major step
forward I love their quarterback I love
everything that they're doing their soup
to nuts how do you respond to something
like that John I echo everything you
said I've been taking a Titan since the
draft John Robinson second year Carroll
majors done everything to help bolster
both sides of the ball I think if
Mariota can spell for the first time
they're going to in the Texas string of
winning the AFC South yeah I'm with you
too I just love their running game I
love their attitude I love their line I
love their quarterback
I love Dick LeBeau there's just so much
pointing upward in Tennessee it's just
and then luck who the heck knows with
him right now what can you tell me about
his readiness best you can tell John
Kerry it's scary I've known Andrews it
was sophomore in high school and the way
he throws the ball rich as you know he
throws the ball already throws it down
the field and you don't just go from 0
to 60 you've got to be able to limber up
and if he doesn't play those first two
games and I don't see a good considering
as he hasn't thrown I'll be stunned if
he's available for the regular season
opener and there's work in Charlotte to
about can Newton is also got shoulder
issues so that
eriell both parts a couple more minutes
of John McClane in Houston Chronicle um
much was made I mean of what the Houston
Astros did not do at the trade deadline
and we had Peter Gammons on the show the
day after the trade deadline and he went
all in on criticizing Houston for only
getting Liriano for the Penn and that's
not really his forte Dallas Keuchel the
next day said he was disappointed how is
that playing out still just about ten
days later John tackle has been shelled
since the game off the AL Lance
McCullers Ben shell since the all-star
break is on the DL their pitching is
abandoned them
and gently no the general manager uh
they loaded the system is loaded with
prospects he should have made a deal and
right now their pitching has been awful
they're both in which was good earlier
found it and as you know rich and the
playoffs it's all about the pitching and
it's too bad because I bet a great
season they're exciting to watch hitters
even know Carlos Perez but now George
Springer just came back but man I just
stunned that Lou no did not make a feel
for at least two starter and a lefty in
the book and besides Liriano who has
basically been awful so do you think
that it might be so desperate that they
can just swallow and just call up the
cash to get Verlander in some sort of a
waiver acquisition and just pay the
money bring Verlander to Houston and try
and win now and and pay essentially I
don't have to say that because that's a
two-for-one deal from eminence wife but
I don't think they'll do that pay that
kind of money and but they should but I
don't see it
okay and and last thing John who's more
dangerous you on Twitter watching the
Texans or Baylor struggle or the mother
of dragons atop her dragon against the
Lannisters John the mother of dragons
breathe fire she takes out everybody in
her path that's not going to happen a
sailor even though that rule is a
terrific coach I can't wait to see what
he can do it
I'm just getting warmed up on Twitter
it's your great follow John you just you
you never do you ever do you ever uh
cover before you hit Send sometimes
never that's why it comes out the way
though okay and you enjoying the game of
Thrones I've seen every episode I
thought last week good at battlefield
seen as I've ever se agree that was
badass stuff John thanks for calling and
appreciate it
bread's my pleasure thank you for having
you got at John McClane the one and only
Houston Chronicle here on the Rich Eisen
show so Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on radio stations across the
country and audience if you like that
please download our app there's lots of
fun things there other than just more of
the videos you just saw you can call us
from the app you can email us from the
app just download it trust me you'll
enjoy